right now illegal drugs are making their
way up
i-15 it is part of an extensive
cross-border drug
network and cartels are using our area
as a pit stop to other western states
tonight only on 8 news now the i-team's
david charn shows us exclusive video of
where this poison is coming from
david well denise the i-team has
reported on huge drug busts over the
past couple months and there's a common
thread if you look closely
thousands and thousands of pounds of
meth coming across the border
and right here to the valley
you can hear the birds in the mexican
jungle but don't let your ears fool you
you're seeing where methamphetamine is
manufactured
before it hits your neighborhood they
prey upon the addiction
of others dan neal is an assistant
special agent in charge of the dea it's
easy to transport
and there's definitely a demand a demand
in a market which begins a thousand
miles away in sinaloa mexico
under the guise of trees jugs full of
chemicals
generators hooked up to machines this is
where cartels are making
enormous amounts of meth they get it
through cars
planes boats you name it
from this tent to the axle of cars meth
makes its way up i-15
destined for us neal says our location
in the southwest
and our abundance of hotel rooms make
las vegas a perfect spoke on the drug
dealing wheel
rest here for the night or and then
distribute it
further north or go out east and more
and more often
drug agents are finding it last year dea
seized more than
and 112 thousand pounds of the drug more
than double the amount they seized just
two years before
dea making this historic bust just last
month outside los
angeles 2200 pounds of meth stashed in
these duffel bags
some which neal says could have ended up
here in the valley
it's multiple times in a month we're
seeing those big seizures
in two recent las vegas cases agents
seized a combined
110 pounds of meth they set up stings in
parking lots
getting hundreds of thousands of doses
off the street
cartels see a market drug agents see a
misdeed
they don't care that you may have a
family that you have friends
or you have a job now it's neil's job to
lead one team
tackling this trade working with other
state and federal agencies
as dealers use our backyard to fuel
what's happening in theirs
it's great enforcement it's great work
by the men and women of the dea
and local law enforcement getting this
stuff off the streets to make things
worse drug agents tell us the pandemic
is actually
fueling more pain and addiction with
overdoses in our area
up 30 percent this spring and summer
compared to the same time last year
so far more than 400 of our family
friends and neighbors
have died from drug overdoses and more
often meth
is playing a role in them brian and
david it's not just the
large amounts we're seeing but also the
chemical makeup
of these drugs it's really concerning
too right so some of those drugs are
being cut with
fentanyl to make it look more pure
fentanyl as we've reported is up to 50
times
more potent than morphine just a few
grains can kill you
immediately and that has dea even more
concerned about
all of this meth flowing into our area
brian and denise